have you guys started uh kicking around
any ideas for any names for the kid
what names for the baby yes
hey what do you want you never answered
none of the questions like that
I don't know I'm ready it's like a
female thing for a
if it's a boy you can't hear it anymore
yeah Junior [__] Junior
blueface Jr blue face Junior
Jonathan Jonathan JR could I name my kid
blueface please don't please God don't
do not do that oh you have that
I think I would do that I think can we
do that
please say no
blue face Porter
um
she gonna do it for sure oh yeah you
cannot have no kid running around here
with their government name being
blueface that poor child
you could do it yeah it's done no it's
not
okay
if I I named you
know he said
my name is Christian your actual name is
Christian yeah yes that's not your fear
he just added wrong
good job uh
did you end up ever
what you should do that
the blue facing don't do that bro I'm
gonna do it do not do that it's a bad
look uh I was gonna ask you oh royal
blue royal blue Royal's a dope name
hey Royal would be a hard name
any joke I was gonna name her after
Christian so it's a girl
if it was a girl I think you just told
us it's a girl
find out for sure on season two of Crazy
In Love
where she will
find out that it's a girl she just let
that slip on accident no I didn't I want
a girl Zeus Network download it on your
phone
how is the pay for doing a TV show with
Zeus is it solid like do they take care
of you guys because
Shawn you're kind of like carrying the
network you know what I mean like she is
on her back because you were on this the
other [__] I carry everything I touched
on my back for sure
[Music]
walking [__] moment this is true